hey guys it's Dr Berg here I wanted to
touch on the difference between eating
raw vegetables and cooked vegetables
first of all the purpose of eating
vegetables is to get the vitamins and
the minerals that you need from a good
source okay now when something is Raw
versus cooked the difference is raw has
enzymes in that vegetable enzymes are
very very good for you and that helps
break down the food and it gives you
great properties Health properties but
the problem is that many people are
missing the normal
enzymes that the pancreas are supposed
to release to be able to digest some of
these fibers in the vegetable for
example
if I consume broccoli it will cause
serious pain in my intestinal tract I
can consume cabbage all day long I could
do kale
but broccoli for some reason tears me up
so that's not necessarily an allergy
it's a missing enzyme that creates
inflammation and it'll feel like I have
a cramp for the next hour so it's very
uncomfortable so what that means is that
somehow along the line I had some damage
in my pancreas and I couldn't I couldn't
generate those enzymes so that's one one
thing but there's other things too if
your stomach has low acid and the way
you know your stomach has low acid is
that you have indigestion like you eat
food it gets stuck there or you have
acid reflux or you have Gerd or you
might have constipation or bloating that
means the acids are lower and if the
acids are lower
it it can't create the triggering effect
for the release of enzymes from your
pancreas so that could be the very
reason why you're not releasing the
enzymes because when I was in college
grad school I was taking the Megaplex of
Rolaids because I had heartburn like
crazy little did I know that was caused
by not enough acid from all the stress
that I was going through but that's
something that you can if you actually
just increase the pH of the stomach
acidify the stomach many times you can
see a great benefit of the full
digestion of even vegetables so that's
something to look at the next thing is
that
you have low good bacteria in your gut
if the bacteria by the way 90 of this
friendly bacteria does most does the
digestion in the small intestine if you
don't have enough of that
then you're going to get a lot of
bloating and excess fermentation and
rotting and all sorts of problems but
these microbes are the things that make
enzymes for these fibers in other words
they live on fiber
now if you're not used to consuming uh
kale or a lot of other vegetables that
you don't normally eat like even
broccoli or cabbage maybe you have just
like iceberg lettuce or spring green and
then you switch over you haven't
developed the enzymes yet and these
microbes have to grow and adapt to your
foods
over a slower period of time before you
can digest them so if you change over
and you feel like you're not losing
weight and you feel bloated all that
means is you got to cut it back you're
not ready to consume that many
vegetables because that's too much fiber
for these microbes to deal with now what
I do is I I have you go back to those
vegetables that you were consuming
before and gradually introduce it until
you can achieve seven to you know ten
cups of vegetables but you have to
sometimes ease into it you can't do it
overnight the other thing you can do is
you can steam the vegetables or cook
them that way you can break them down a
little bit more and it's a lot easier on
the system to digest and you still get
the same minerals you might not have all
the vitamins but you still get the good
minerals that you need from these
vegetables so that's one way and then
also fermented vegetables like
sauerkraut kimchi all these fermented
pickles those are really easy to digest
because the lactic acid from the
bacteria in that they make that from has
already broke it down for you so you can
consume some of that and that will
really help your system but again some
people can't tolerate too much so what I
like to do go for some raw but try not
to go too much to the point where you
feel bloated so you have to adjust that
adjust the amount of raw vegetables
until you have no bloating okay and no
side effects but again we have to slowly
go into this make sure you maybe
increase your acidity in your stomach
maybe use a a probiotic to start
building up or just start off slowly
introducing over time so you can develop
your own microbes and your body can
adapt to that situation okay so that's
the only point I want to make between
these two so go ahead and comment below
and I'll see in the next video